why would i betray we all have our  secrets  just to be get to yours yet  the world is arming faster than we can  respond  where's double-oh-seven  I need a favor brother you're the only  one I trust for this  the world's moved on commander bond you  would double Oh two years so stay in  your lane you get in my way I will put a  bullet in your knee  that works that's what you two would get  along named Vonda  James Bond so you're not dead hello Q  I've missed you  is the most valuable asset this country  has if you feel yourself losing control  I'm not gonna lose  control  James you gave up everything for her  when her secret finds its way out  there'll be the death of him  what is it you don't know what this is  James Bond license to kid history of  violence I could be speaking to my own  reflection on the Oscars die with her  body mine will survive long after I'm  gone  history isn't kind to men who play God  [Music]  you  you